ربما يذكر البعض لحظات توبيخ الفنانه
الاسبانيه هبه عبوك لزوجها نجم الكره
المغربيه اشرف حكيمي عاقبه نهايه مباراه
المغرب والبرتغال في كاس العالم لانه لم
ياتي اليها للاحتفال معها اولا هبه هي
اليوم في قلب الحدث فقد كشفت تقارير صحفيه
عن مضيها قدما في اجراءات الطلاق مع اشرف
حكيمي وذلك بالتزامن مع اتهامي باغتصاب
فتاه في باريس الانفصال كان مطروحا منذ
مده لان الفنانه الاسبانيه تكبر زوجها
بخمس سنوات وكانت تعتبر انه غير مستعد
للارتباط جديا لكن الانفصال تحول اليوم
الى اجراءات طلاق حقيقيه زوجه حكيمه لم
تعد تظهر معه في المناسبات الرسميه لاسيما
في احتفال اللاعب الافضل في العالم ما
يؤيد الاحاديث حول نهايه العلاقه بينهما
بشكل قريب
[موسيقى]